All of these people's feelings
are falling from the sky.
Violet.
Major.
"To my beloved Major Gilbert.
How are you?
I hope all is well with you.
Where are you right now?
I hope you are not stressed out.
Spring, summer, autumn, and winter.
Many seasons have passed,
but I am still waiting for your return.
At first, I did not understand.
I did not understand any of your feelings.
But I started learning about emotions,
from this new life you have provided me.
Through writing letters for others.
Through the people I have met.
I still believe that you are still alive
out there somewhere.
That is why
I will continue to live my life.
I may not know what lies ahead,
but I will simply live.
And if we should ever meet again,
this is what I would tell you.
I now understand what the words...
'I love you' mean."